Welcome to the An and Ashley show, I'm Ashley and today's episode we're going to be
talking about some holiday drink options, but before we get started please hit the like
and subscribe button and the little alert button on the top of your screen if you're watching
on YouTube.
So Anne, what did you put together for a holiday drink?
Nears is coming up too!
Yeah, I did.
There's a lot of drinking to be done.
So you can either make these as mocktails or cocktails, so right now we're just doing mocktails.
This is a honey rosemary drink, but if you have a bad cut to it, it's a honey rosemary
column, since what they call them.
So what I have done here is I made a simple syrup of honey and so two thirds cup of honey
with two thirds cup of water, so equal parts honey and water, and then four sprigs of rosemary
and then you cook that down, boil it, cook it down until it's really syrupy, and then
it's just ice and the cute little garnish here, it's a sprig of rosemary and you have lemon,
a maraschino cherry which don't eat it, it's just for the bright red color because it does
have red dye for me in it, and then a pellegrino, which is a lemon pellegrino, so you can just
fill up the glass with your pellegrino, and then you can add the simple syrup just
to taste, depending on how sweet you like it, so maybe I don't know, a tablespoon or something,
and then if you're adding, you know, a little bit of vodka, then a shot of vodka, but
you don't have to.
And then the rosemary is really the star ingredient, it just makes for such a just great tasting
fragrance, it just smells like the holidays, and I think it looks really cute too, it
looks really cute.
Yeah, do you just use any flavored water or unflavored, or yeah, but you can use just unflavored
natural, again this has lemon, you could use lime too, but since we're using lemon as
a garnish I chose lemon, so I love it, yeah, it looks really cute, okay, so I have, it's
a blueberry lime cocktail, that's mint, right, yeah, so the hint of mint, that's optional,
hint of mint, it's optional, we like mint, so we added it, maybe do too, maybe you don't
then leave it out, so I made a simple syrup too, it consists of blueberry, so fresh blueberries,
I'm sure you could use frozen too, but you heat it up with a cup of blueberries, a cup
of water, and a cup of sweetener, so it called for sugar, we used monk fruit, and the
seraphinids on was actually really good, okay, you could put that on pancakes, you told me
because it would be really good, or over ice cream, or over ice cream, yeah, yeah, you can do
all that, like a dairy brew ice cream, yes, a nice cream, a nice cream, so yeah, we did add
one leaf of mint because the leaves are massive. So just one was enough for flavor.
Heat it up to a boil and then, or you could put it in the microwave like I did until I cut,
got hot enough. I could start into a syrup and then I put it in a blender to top it off and they
get really blended with the mint as well. But otherwise heat it up. Okay. And then you take, I took
um, this is two ounces and two and four ounces. So about half a cup of the simple syrup. You know,
I'm just gonna do two ounces. That looks like enough. Yeah. When I was doing this earlier,
I used a bigger glass. Okay. Okay. So half a cup or two ounces of the simple syrup into the glass.
And then I just mix lime and lemon. So I did part lime to my cover. I don't know. I just poured
and then lemon as well. And you can play around with whichever your favorite. The drink just called
for lime, but we had both available and tastes really good. So like both of them. And that's it. Mix
it up. Garnish was just blue berries and lime. So look at that. That's different. Yes. I like the colors
kind of it sold me on the hot day drink. Yeah. We had happy new years in mind. Right. So hopefully,
I gave you some ideas, some inspiration for your holiday entertaining. Um, like and share this
episode with your friends. If your friends are struggling with, you know, what, you know, every party
has to have a signature drink, right? Absolutely. So these are some fun ones. Um, thank you. And let us know
if you have any ideas for show episodes that you would like us to talk about. Um, thank you. And
stay tuned for the next episode. Cheers. And you could add vodka for champagne. Anything to these
drinks. Would you speak of it at any one of those? Oh boy. Yeah.